how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we have
some pretty great news concerning
spider-man 3
and the wanda vision series now ever
since back in
april when kobit 19 and this whole
pandemic started marvel studios has had
to push
all of their phase 4 projects back and
pretty much all of phase 4 has been
delayed at this time
with the exception of one project which
we'll talk about in this video but it's
about time that we got some good news
because it seems like every week marvel
studios is delaying at least
one project or another but today we're
actually going to talk about some pretty
good changes that marvel studios is
making good for them and good for the
fans and that actually includes
rearranging their
original phase four slate to where it
was in the first place but don't worry
the stories will still connect
and still make sense and i'll break it
all down in this video but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe with
notifications on so you don't miss any
video concerning the mcu
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a hawkeye
funko pop all you got to do to enter
subscribe like this video and leave a
comment about the video down below
so like i said we have two bits of news
today one concerning spider-man 3 and
one concerning the one division series
and we'll kick it off with spider-man
3 news now some of you may heard that
spider-man 3 got its release date
changed and this is true but i'm going
to explain why it's actually good
you see most of the delays that have
happened to the phase 4 lineup because
of kovan 19 have been due to either
production delays on the studio side or
due to theaters not reopening
but in our case with spider-man 3 it's
actually
a strategic decision made by marvel
studios and sony together
yesterday at comic-con home disney
announced that avatar 2 which originally
had the december 17
2021 spot got delayed it got pushed back
but spider-man is going to be taking
that spot
now spider-man 3 was originally
scheduled for november 5th of 2021 a
month before this new date
so yes it did get pushed back a month
but here's why
sony and marvel did this it is now a
christmas release
and due to the fact that it's coming out
on christmas it's almost a guarantee
that it's a billion
dollar movie spider-man far from home
was the first
spider-man film to make a billion
dollars and the fact that spider-man 3
is going to be on christmas pretty much
guarantees that it'll do the same
so that's why they made this decision to
postpone spider-man 3 a month
it wasn't due to the fact that there are
problems with production or tom holland
is getting caught up
filming uncharted it's simply a
strategic move and spider-man 3 is still
set to tentatively
begin filming in september which means
we should be getting a relative amount
of information about spider-man 3
starting in september including the
title and following that the teaser
trailer probably at the beginning of
2021 either february or march so yes it
did get pushed back a month but it's
good news because it's going to help the
movie do really really well in the
theaters and it didn't get pushed back
because of any production delays and
then the other great news is about one
division and the fact that it is still
actually set for a 2020 release date
last weekend was a pretty confusing time
for the one division series first
deadline reported that one division was
scheduled for october which was actually
a typo that they fixed to say december
but then the hollywood reporter came out
and said that the show was delayed until
spring of 2021.
however as it turns out this was
incorrect and they have since
then corrected their story in their
article when they corrected it they said
other shows include
one division later in 2020 loki in
spring of 2021
and then the hawkeye series so the great
news is that the one division series has
not been delayed and is still
hopeful for the december spot now this
would probably mean that the one
division series may be
the first phase four project that we see
the falcon and the winter soldier has
been delayed plenty of times and they
haven't finished their filming yet
whereas
one division has finished all their
filming and given this fact and given
the fact that the falcon in the winter
soldier series continuously gets delayed
one division is most likely going to be
the first phase 4 project that we see
now some of you have asked me how will
this affect the continuity of the mcu
and the timeline and the answer is
it won't marvel studios won't release
the one division series before
the falcon and the winter soldier if
it's going to mess anything up as far as
the timeline with the mcu
so either the one division series isn't
going to reference the events of the
falcon and the winter soldier or they'll
simply just do a little bit of editing
and fix anything that might have
referenced the falcon in the winter
soldier but hopefully things get rolling
soon for the falcon and the winter
soldier and we don't get too much of a
delay on their part anymore but the
great news is that the one division
series should still be coming
in december and it's already filmed so
their delays should be pretty rare at
this point since they're pretty much
just editing and they're doing that
remotely right now
so hopefully this sticks and we'll
actually be getting the one division
series in december
right after the black widow movie so
great news for marvel studios today let
me know what you think about this news
in the comments down below
and let me know if you'd like to see the
one division series or the falcon in the
winter soldier series first don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up to date on all things relating to the
mcu for live updates you can follow me
on twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof